me gustaría que le pongas pausa al vídeo
y pienses en cuánto es 64 menos 31 muy
bien ahora vamos a pensar en esto juntos
así es que qué es lo que 64 realmente
significa bueno pues podemos usar los
valores posicionales para pensar en esto
el 6 está en el lugar de las decenas de
genes
y el 4 está en el lugar de las unidades
unidades entonces estas 6 en este lugar
significa 6 de escenas
y grupos de 10 unidades o diez cajitas
si lo quieres ver así y lo podemos
visualizar por aquí nunca y tenemos seis
decenas
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 grupos de 10 6
decenas y otra forma de verlo es que
aquí tenemos 60 cajitas 60 unidades
acomodadas en grupos de 10 y después
tenemos 4 en el lugar de las unidades
aunque yo sé que tenemos 4 unidades y
bueno pues las tenemos por aquí también
unidades aquí lo que tenemos es 64 6
decenas y 4 unidades y aquí todo esto
juntos son 64 cajitas 60 de ellas están
aquí de color azul y 4 de ellas son
amarillas ahora lo que queremos hacer es
quitar 31 pero que es 31 pues 31 son
tres decenas y una unidad y las queremos
restar o sea las queremos quitar lo
primero que vamos a hacer es quitar esta
unidad tenemos una unidad y la queremos
quitar pues porque estamos restando lo
que ya estamos gastando una unidad y
tres decenas así es que vamos por aquí y
quitamos una unidad y entonces cuántas
unidades nos quedan pues ahora nos
quedan tres unidades
tres unidades cuatro unidades menos una
unidad son tres unidades y ahora vamos a
pensar en las decenas
empezamos con seis decenas por aquí
están las seis decenas pero ahora le
queremos restar tres decenas
así es que pues vamos a quitar las aquí
quitamos una decena quitamos otra decena
y tres decenas y ahora cuántas decenas
nos quedaron pues nos quedaron estas
otras tres decenas cierto nos quedaron
tres decenas
así es que seis decenas menos tres
decenas son tres decenas 64 menos 31 es
33 3 decenas y 3 unidades que también lo
podemos ver por aquí nos quedaron tres
decenas una decena dos decenas tres
decenas y otras tres unidades 1 2 y 3